[Música]
Bienvenidos a la crónica de medio
ambiente hoy el agua y su protección son
protagonistas en Honduras tienen un plan
de rescate para salvar el lago de Yojoa
el único lago natural y una de las
mayores reservas de agua dulce del país
amenazado por la contaminación de la
agro O la tala la ganadería y la pesca a
gran escala nuestra corresponsal Kenia
Torres visitó la zona y este de su
reporte
el lago de Yojoa la mayor Fuente de Agua
Dulce de Honduras se encuentra en
peligro debido a la contaminación y a la
explotación irregular de sus recursos
este Batallón verde liderado por Diego
Escobar intenta hacer un trabajo de
vigilancia y protección del Lago para
preservar su vida nosotros desempeñamos
a la hora aquí de lo que es la
protección de la flora y fauna de los
recursos marinos que pertenece aquí en
lo que es el lado de Yojoa lo que se
trata de hacer aquí es hacer que la
población de pescadores tenga
concientización de Qué pasaría si si
explotan demasiado lo que es los
recursos de acá en los últimos a 12 años
el espejo de agua del Lago ha sido
invadido por una alga que es sumado a la
explotación desmedida de sus recursos ha
provocado un desastre ambiental Los
Pescadores han decidido colaborar con
las normas para proteger el lago Aunque
han mermado sus ingresos
que si lo quitan la pesca Pues de que
vamos a vivir y qué vamos a trabajar Es
lo mismo pues pero no se puede regular
pienso yo con estas medidas el instituto
de conservación forestal espera
garantizar el uso sostenible de los
recursos del Lago y regular las
concesiones para la explotación
es un asunto de seguridad nacional por
todo la riqueza ecosistémica que
representa además de la parte de
producción de energía de de del Estado
así como toda su dinámica hidrológica
Entonces es el único lago que tenemos en
el país y es un bien común de todos los
hondureños De no ser detenida la
contaminación según los especialistas el
lago podría desaparecer en unos 50 años
afectando el suministro de servicio de
agua a más de un millón de habitantes de
la zona así como la generación de
energía eléctrica y las diferentes
especies de flora y fauna
de Honduras nos vamos a Ecuador donde
están creando zonas de protección en
torno a las fuentes de agua desde 2018
hasta hoy se han establecido 20 áreas de
protección hídrica que miden 175.000
hectáreas la meta del gobierno es que a
2025 se hayan protegido
285.000 hectáreas estos lugares están
divididos en tres clases zonas de
conservación de restauración y de uso
sostenible las últimas son para que la
población pueda producir con ganadería o
agricultura pero por ejemplo con
rotación de cultivos usando
fertilizantes orgánicos y evitando que
los animales beban del agua del río
directamente entre otros métodos
sostenibles así las áreas de protección
hídrica protegen el agua declarada de
interés público y salvaguardan los
ecosistemas como nos lo explicó Cristina
de la paz de nature conservador el
momento que se establece una área de
protección hídrica lo que pasa es que ya
hay una estructura legal que permite
ser un poco más estricto en esa
conservación de las fuentes de agua Qué
son las fuentes de agua principalmente
son los ecosistemas es decir bosques son
páramos que retienen el agua al rato que
el agua cae estos ecosistemas absorben
esa agua la la
purifican y también la empiezan a
digamos
a mantener en sus acuíferos la absorben
Y esa agua se mantiene en los acuíferos
y esos acuíferos luego hay toda una
regulación hídrica para que eso se vaya
soltando poquito a poquito y para que
los ríos tengan agua constante y
proteger los ríos importa Porque de
todos los ecosistemas del mundo son los
más degradados Ecuador lo sabe Y por eso
a finales de enero lanzaron el área de
protección hídrica más grande del país
llamada aguarico chingual y cofanes que
mide casi lo mismo que cien mil estadios
de fútbol esta protege desde los páramos
andinos hasta el agua que llega al río
Amazonas a través del Río y sus
afluentes Juan Pablo Fajardo director de
la zonal de sucumbíos del Ministerio de
ambiente Nos contó la importancia de
estos ecosistemas para combatir la
crisis climática y la pérdida de
biodiversidad
lo que garantizamos es agua para todos
agua de calidad y cantidad y también la
seguridad la soberanía alimentaria que
es sumamente importante y de hecho
entran muchas variables como la la no
extracción de minerales los recursos
naturales se quedan en el suelo la
conservación
del Bosque la conservación de vida
Silvestre y una infinidad de cosas que
vamos a lograr con esto Pero qué es lo
más importante de las áreas de
protección
hídrica Cristina lo resume en dos
cualidades que lo diferencian de otros
proyectos en América Latina organizar en
torno al agua y pensar en los habitantes
parte de su Innovación es que primero
tiene un enfoque del de Fuente de Agua
que esto es algo que o sea de la
protección de los ríos y del agua como
tal Generalmente todos los esquemas de
conservación han tenido un enfoque
muy de de de de ecosistema terrestre
pero también lo otro es que estos
innovador porque también es una área de
protección donde es hay gente viviendo
ahí La idea es con las mismas personas
trabajar para ver cómo se puede seguir
conservando lo que ya está en buen
estado hasta aquí La Crónica Vean este
capítulo en la sección programas de
France 24.com y abajo aparecen mis redes
sociales nos vemos
[Música]